??????????
Alright, Jack I have a surprise for you-
Welcome e-back everyone (^_^)
"Welcome back everyone! We're exactly where we left off."
exactl-
"Nothing changed!"
Okay Jack, behind you there's a- surprise
"Really?"
"I hear you placing things"
"Can I turn around now?"
J: Tell me when I can turn around
P: Turn around!
I think you will like it >:)
*distant maaa*
"OH MY GOD-"
"IT'S DOORS! :D"
"How did you know?!"
"How did you know I liked doors?"
I just know! Irish people like doors, right?
"Yeah! We love to be oppressed and stay inside." (me too)
"I'm already doing the accent again ..(laughing)"
[pewds and jack have a laugh]
Stop. Doin'. The accent, Jack!
"It's prison! Just like my mom used to make..."
P: Oh-
"What was that?!"
"What were you doing?!"
[high-pitched voice] Nothing, nothing! ^_^
Today Jack, we should try and aim for Nether.
I feel like it's time.
"Ooh, we need to get obsidian..."
But how we get obsidian?
Let's ask water sheep.
"Water sheep, which direction- YOU TAKE DOOR FROM WATER SHEEP!"
Oh sorry-heeeEEEE
"he need door."
P: he need door.
Okay, knock first, knock knock
"Knock knock, water sheep!"
He said yes-
"chop chop" (?)
Okay-
"He said- he said yes?"
I'm tryna' roleplay, Jack! :(
"Water sheep! Where do we go- in our Minecraft adventure today?"
(water sheep noise)
"In-inside?
(baaahh)
"The treasure was inside all along?"
[pewds laughs]
"Water sheep, what are you saying?"
P: The treasure is our heart all along, oh my god ! So we build-